Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Yes, that’s right, Microsoft’s new AI watched
about a 100 million clips from Youtube. And
today we are going to ask one simple question:
what did it learn? I’ll tell you in a moment.
You see, today text to image AIs are all the rage.
By just doing as little as entering a text prompt,
we can now create all kinds of images, and
even videos. A true miracle of science,
really. And I often hear people saying that
they can’t wait to be able to be able to express
their creativity by creating movies with them.
However, not so fast. We can already do that
with Google’s and Runway’s technique and there
are even more out there. But for some reason,
I rarely hear people talking about sound.
Well, this new paper solves exactly that.
Now, wait a minute. We are going to
invoke the Second Law of Papers here,
which says that whatever you are
thinking about, there is already
a Two Minute Papers episode on that. For
instance, we talked about Google’s MusicLM,
an incredible AI-based technique that takes a text
prompt and synthesizes incredible music. Listen.
This is fantastic. Also, our seasoned Fellow
Scholars remember an earlier episode where we
talked about a brilliant handcrafted graphics
paper that did something that was previously
thought to be almost impossible. So what
is that? Well, hold on to your papers,
because it took an already existing
video clip or computer animation,
and synthesized sounds for it.
And the results were outstanding.
Yes, through the power of computer
graphics research, this was possible
approximately 10 years ago. Yes, you heard
it right. This paper was published 10 years
ago at the SIGGRAPH conference. That
is an incredible place with similarly
high-quality papers. Now, with all that said,
what does this new AI paper add to the mix?
And I would say, everything. Now, I hear
you asking, Doctor, what do you mean by
this? Exactly what I said. This is an any to any
generation technique that also includes audio.
Here are some of my favorite examples.
One, if we enter a piece of text,
like “Fireworks in the sky”, it synthesizes
video and audio at the same time!
Or, we can write "Dive in
coral reef”, and we get this.
Two, we can also go the other way around. If we
have a text description of a painterly style,
and look, no mention of ships at all. And we
also add this sound sample. And as a result,
we get this image. So cool!
But wait, it gets even better. Or three, we can
even enter a text prompt plus a piece of audio,
and out comes, not just an image, but…oh
my, even a piece of video. As requested,
the camera indeed goes forward ever
so slightly. Good job, little AI!
And, we can also perform the usual suspects, text
to image, a piece of audio to an image, or if we
have a cracking photo, we can even ask for it
to create a video with a somewhat similar vibe.
Wow. It feels like this can do absolutely
everything. Now, every single one of you
Fellow Scholars see that the quality of these
results is not the greatest, however. Remember,
two years ago, we had DALL-E 1 for image
generation, a year later, DALL-E 2, and now,
a year later, Midjourney can do this. And I
would not be surprised if today we would be at
a DALL-E 1 moment for full film, or in other
words, video+audio generation. Just imagine
what we will be capable of two more papers down
the line. My goodness. What a time to be alive!
And if you don’t mind, I can’t resist quickly
showing a really cool computer graphics paper
to you. This is a new technique that is able
to simulate situations with a brutally large
number of collisions. These simulations
contain objects that are built up from
millions and millions ot tetrahedra. From
little pyramids, if you will. For instance,
when squishing this ball, it can
simulate what happens next. Incredible.
It can also simulate Davy Jones’ and
friends falling into a glass box,
and other, complex, knotty situations. All
this in a matter of seconds. Absolutely
incredible graphics research. Sorry, I
couldn’t resist showing this to you. I
hope you Fellow Scholars don’t mind.
Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!